bonjour à tous j'ai rencontré il ya
quelques jours à l'ifa à berlin la
société française nico pour parler de
son tout nouveau smartphone de ses tout
nouveaux smartphones les ue les modèles
view you prime view xl view des
smartphones qui sont très sympas et
justement on va parler ensemble
si vous ne me connaissez pas je
m'appelle monsieur boureima chaîne parle
de stratégie digitale de stratégie du
tube pour vous aider à aller plus loin
c'est en voisin digital d'envol
stratégie sur youtube vous invite à vous
abonner à la chaîne les activer la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune
publication
et justement j'ai rencontré cette
société marseillaise à berlin sur leur
stand
un stand qui était grandiose magnifique
et j'ai pu tester et voir les
smartphones les nouveaux view
directement mais je peux vous le dire
les produits sont super bien j'emmène
directement à berlin avec moi pour en
parler c'est parti il convient de lancer
de nouveaux produits qui sont vraiment
deux en fait trois nouveaux produits
vous avez tout d'abord le view ce
smartphone la levée ou xl qui est la
version forcément ici avec un écran qui
est quand même beaucoup plus grand du
biou et vous aviez le vieux prague qui a
plein plein de qualités et on va déposer
sa ensemble le jury aura un écran 5 7
pouces en 18,9 et celle un produit qui
est vraiment très agréable en termes de
prise en main déjà une caméra 13
mégapixels à l'arrière et sur l'avant ce
qui est vraiment très très bien lorsque
vous faites des vidéos vous avez une
caméra en 16 mégapixels vous avez donc
une qualité qui est vraiment extrêmement
bonnes à la vente ce qui fait que
lorsque vous allez chez théo vidéo comme
ceci vous allez forcément vous voir dans
une excellente qualité en ayant un vrai
retour moniteurs et ça c'est vraiment un
super bon point vous avez un processeur
à quatre coeurs vous avez vraiment un
produit qui est super sympa avec plein
de fonctionnalités différentes un
produit que vous pouvez les verrouiller
grâce au capteur que vous avez là
hier capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est très pratique à la différence
d'autres produits concurrente où vous
avez toujours le risque de mettre le
doigt directement sur la caméra là vous
avez capteur canon dessous ce qui fait
qu'en terme de prise en main c'est
vraiment très très facile et très sympa
alors vous avez le view vous avez le
vieux xl la grande différence avec
l'excellent forcément c'est la taille de
l'écran vous avez un écran quasiment 6
pouces 5,99 housse en termes de
spécifications techniques c'est
exactement la même chose entre le view
et le violoncelle la différence est
vraiment envoyer la taille de l'écran
vous avez 32 gigas de mémoire et 3 giga
de ram pour ce téléphone concernant le
vieux vous avez une batterie de deux
mille neuf cent millions terreur et le
luxe l3000 mis en péril le produit que
c'est que ce soit le view le vieux xl
est disponible en quatre couleurs vous
l'avais en moi couleur or turquoise et
vous l'avez en rouge alors celui-là
c'est le view prime et il est disponible
également sur le bio est vieux lixheim
et on m'a parlé du view prime un produit
qui est vraiment super intéressant parce
qu'il a beaucoup de qualités et
notamment en termes de qualité vidéo
c'est un produit qui est un écran 5,7
pouces avec un ratio 18/9 64 giga de
mémoire et 4 gigas de ram une batterie 3
millions terreur et une prise en main
qui est vraiment très sympa vous avez
derrière et si la petite touche pour le
déverrouiller rapidement à l'aria vous
avez une caméra 16 mégapixels avec le
flash qui est ici et à l'avant vous avez
le grand avantage d'avoir une double
caméra
vous avez une caméra en 20 mégapixels et
en 8 mégapixels qui vous offre de
grandes possibilités c'est d'avoir
j'irai de pouvoir shooter avec une très
bonne qualité avec une caméra se passe
et aussi d'avoir un très grand angle et
ça c'est juste d'être lâche l'une sur
les caméras en 8 mégapixels qui vous
donne le dira le cadre classique comme
on peut le retrouver sur les différents
smartphones et maintenant on va essayer
avec le grand-angle enfin mégapixels et
on peut
qu'on a effectivement une vraie
différence la qualité d'image est là et
c'est vraiment très très très pratique
vous avez aussi une fonctionnalité pour
avoir viré en font un peu fou un côté
blur sur vos images ça vous permet de
ressortir par rapport à votre fonds
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
extrêmement pratique un produit qui est
très bien et qui a surtout la
particularité de ne pas être cher c'est
un produit qui est disponible à 269
euros partir de la fin du mois de
septembre et je voulais en termes de
qualité prix on n'a rien à reprocher à
ce téléphone
il est vraiment extrêmement bien fait et
en plus il a la particularité d'être
fabriqués en france
voilà ce qu'on peut lire aujourd'hui sur
ces trois modèles view view prime view
xl sont tous les trois des smartphones
qui sont équipés du processeur
snapdragon 425 pour résumer si vous
voulez vous avez la même base sur les
trois smartphones le xl1 écran plus
grand que le view et le prime et mieux
équipées en termes de tarifs on devrait
retrouver le view à 179,99 euros
le vieux os x est là 229,99 et le vieux
prague la 279 euros à moins de 300 euros
vous avez un smartphone qui tourne sous
android 7 points guga avec des caméras
qui sont bonne qualité un processeur qui
fonctionne un téléphone qui est cohérent
alors effectivement opa lui demander la
lune vous aurez pas les nouvelles
technologies de déverrouillage vous
n'aurez pas tous les gadgets mais si
vous voulez juste un bon smartphone
fabriqué en france
pas cher faut pas hésiter cette nouvelle
gamme de view saura vous séduire
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo dites
moi ce que vous pensez de ce téléphone
view violoncelle est-ce que vous pensez
que son du téléphone que vous pourriez
avoir est-ce qu'il vous séduisent wind
ont marqué ma tout sans commentaires et
on discute ensemble je vous invite à
vous abonner à machete passera toujours
plus de contenu pour vous aider dans
votre stratégie youtube est votre
stratégie digitale
si vous avez des questions vous pouvez
me joindre sur twitter @ monsieur dreux
et avec le hashtag est monsieur greu
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
et d'ici là portez vous bien ça lui
[Musique]